hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story things in the night
my name is markiplier and we got a jar
and a barn door key and we're ready to
roll but all the citizens dead really
dead maybe I can find someone in the
village that knows if my brother is
alive
I think it's also helping my immersion
in this story is because I've actually
blocked out my windows completely not
just like whatever sheet or anything
like that or draw the curtains I
actually stuff things in my window to
make sure it's completely dark because
[Music]
because I don't pre-record stuff usually
idly record on the same day so that
means I usually record the morning to
play these I'm hearing these squeaks
distracting me
how do I get in this big building is
there a way in any way I'm normally I
record in the mornings which means that
I have to block everything out and I
really took extra steps to block things
out so it is dark in mine I know the
mayor's house oh okay
strange Huff's just said the mayor's
house
they're monsters wandering around sorry
for the low frame rates when I'm walking
down here I don't know if you guys could
tell or anything but it's just the way
the map is built there's a lot of stuff
the engines not meant for that at the
moment anyway in the last episode I got
a barn door key and I remember that this
I'm probably gonna have to get something
and then heat it up I'm not exactly sure
what is that oh man some crazy stuff is
going on in here ah oil yeah I finally
completed the serum I needed but it must
pass through a living thing to give it a
new life which is the third stage i
injected the pigs with it and it killed
them but it makes the theorem come to
life
so it means I can use it on dead humans
as well all I need to do is heat it for
the last stage and it will turn into an
acid like blood and all the eggs in it
will hatch then it will truly be
complete and I'll be able to bring back
the dead I must remember that there are
four stages to make the blood the
letters ripped so he can hide how to
make the blood but there may be some
pigs that have up to the third stage of
the blood in it then all I'll have to do
is heat it up well why why would I want
to do that why would I be interested in
that why suddenly would I go crazy and
want to go god these these bodies were
laying around maybe mine there anything
behind there
oh man I'm hearing these squeaks I swear
either I'm going crazy or there are some
squeaks going on okay here the pigs but
how do I get I have a bone soft looks
like I can get some fresh blood from
this pig
I'll need a knife a glass jar or
something like that it must have some of
the acid I need why how do you know you
need that we'll have a glass jar now
Brown maybe or maybe I gotta cut it
first
what oh come on don't be like that it's
good it'll work fine
I gotta find like a knife or something
[ __ ]
nice or maybe I do maybe I'm just not
trying hard enough it says I saw that
can be used to cut wood or even flesh no
am i absolutely sure that I cannot put
this on the ground
all right I must be missing a knife
there's got to be another houses what
the hell you got to be another house
that's dark that I can get into I've got
to be missing something so I'll go back
up try to look for houses on the right
side then are dark
I mean this one's dark but this is the
one that was locked right okay I need to
find a key for that one oh man I'm still
hearing the squeaking oh yeah this is to
the ruins I'm supposed to explore the
room Wow haha Oh God
pound just pops up right by some weird
ruin man
freaky deaky okie dokie
all right moose man what the hell okay
there's a fakey fake emus man let's just
see what the deal is order all that I've
read that at once
the note hasn't changed
man I tell you this custom swords really
son
oh hello baby how you do why
holy crap
then I love it I love the work this
guy's done is crazy
aha there's a key there probably to that
door brother if you're reading this note
you've made it pretty far I'm proud of
you I was able to steal some notes from
dad explaining how he opened a rift to
another place you must move fast here's
what you'll be needing father has made
some type of blood but you may find more
info about it in our town all I know
about this blood is that you have to put
it on the left pedestal and nothing else
can be put in the first place it is
found of some kind of artifact that's
very old and with almost no power left
if you can find this thing remember that
this is the second object you have to
place on the pedestal that's all I could
find in the notes next and last is a
body part of a pure hearth person seems
like a head is what you'll need from
what I can read it in the notes then
you'll have to give some of your own
blood and hope that everything will work
remember the correct order the power
that father woke up comes from that
place beyond the rift so it should be a
really dangerous place but if you're
lucky it will lead you to the castle
okay all right so I've totally forgotten
anyway I place things in pedestals I got
a key to the door which would probably
give me a tour knife this is how I know
I need the blood I should have I
probably was supposed to come here first
and that way I know I needed
now things are starting to make sense
and I was told to come to the ruins
first so I should have known about that
man this is really really cool I like
this a lot
wonderful so I'm already gonna recommend
that you guys go out and get this custom
story because this is this is amazing
so now I can go to that old house the
old door an estranged or whatever door
it was I can go there
oh that's squeaking again I don't know
what it is I've never heard that before
I don't know what wolves up with those
monsters that just popped up in the town
and it's like I never ran into him and I
was running all around town anyway
whiskey Oh what oh the strange house
that's the mayor's house okay I got it I
got it
once it one thing I will say this guy
does not build stairs very well because
you'll see when I come up to this
strange mayor's house
I mean check out these stairs uh-oh
there we go but I won't knock that
against him
this house is so peculiar in strange Oh
chairs Oh dead bodies to have known
seems like some freaky deaky rituals
were going on
looking for a knife or something knife
shard of glass something that can cut ha
found you let me explore a bit up here
first okay ah thank you
absolutely what I need I'm burning
through quick Oh what's down here that's
locked anyway
alright let's see come on
oh yo oh my goodness oh no way
come on oh why oh there's a knife I said
oh my god there we go God that is the
hardest thing to open em oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy what close it close it
close it close the [ __ ] thing
hey buddy don't mind me I'm scarier than
you are
hello
why would these things close did he
leave no no ha ha oh damn I can't
freakin close done opening
did he leave okay all right okay
Oh in an alley huh don't look at it a
lot of these guys I've never seen one
actually bust through a closet or
something I don't know if they can
probably it seems weird that a closet is
like the uber defense against all
monsters a wonderful machine for Pixies
is even gonna have closets in it they're
much too convenient
oh man was doing
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna let me go
I'm just gonna go haha can't get me okay
I got the knife I can get the blood I
still need to find a key to the old
house that old house in the back but I
don't know where to get that
screeching music
oh I hear a monster like so now I have
the knife I get the blood and I can get
out I still don't know why
oh the saw of course they said something
about needing someone's head I'm gonna
have to cut off a grip his head again
okay oh that's squeaking
[Music]
just have to castle that I need to go to
why do I need to go through another
dimension to get to that castle okay God
to piggy piggies gods in that Nazi
sorry piggies what no no really
oh you got to be kidding oh that one
that was the big filled up now it's
going next
he got up that monster got up we got up
you can't do anything about me up here
what oh you startled me
oh man ah
yeah I shouldn't be having bright buy
the candle what do I do
oh my God he's like standing right there
looking at me oh okay
ah what do I get away do I do
oh I just got a run for it don't I oh no
I don't I can wait all right that's all
the time I got for this after this so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part bye-bye